and it is time now for the press preview
our first look at the front pages so
over the next half an hour or so 25
minutes we'll be taking a look at the
headlines
with the daily mirror columnist susie
boniface and the conservative
commentator
tim montgomery abbot first let's take a
look at some of the front pages
and you might detect something of a
theme here um the eye's headline is
pretty blunt
cummings declares war on johnson as the
prime minister's former chief adviser
issues a scathing rebuke of his ex-boss
and denies any involvement in the
leaking of private texts
similarly the male in a fighting mood
doms all out war with the pm
as i said a theme developing here the
telegraph saying cummings declares war
on the pm uh the torturous war metaphors
continuing in the times with mr johnson
dubbing the prime minister
unethical and foolish
here's the ft cummings lashes out at
johnson
the paper calls his statements an
extraordinary blind extraordinary
broadside i should say
astonishing to to the guardian an
astonishing attack this time
i mean while the sun reports that the
former footballer ryan giggs could be
jailed
after being charged with assaulting two
women and with engaging in
controlling or coercive behavior
and the express uh chooses to lead with
the possibility that we'll be able to
ditch
wearing masks by the summer
uh we are joined tonight as i said bye
susie boniface and
tim montgomery guys lovely to see you
both and
oh what should we talk about tonight the
weather
the fact we're all at work on a friday
no let's talk about dominic cummings the
daily mail seems
a fairly decent place to start susie
just just reminders as to
to the point that we have gotten this
story a rather short blog from mr
cummings uh released today
uh essentially trying to put the boot
into the prime minister
yes so to sum it up um well marina heard
from the guardian has done betting this
to me today by saying who would have
thought that dominic cummings would turn
out to be the craziest x that boris
johnson had
but to sum it up the allegations are
firstly
it was your girlfriend's mate's fault
secondly
uh the prime minister stopped talking to
him
in 20 about his wallpaper in 2020 when
he told him he was a criminally insane
[ __ ]
and thirdly honestly says dominic
cummings
i thought boris johnson was completely
competent and had loads of integrity
what a surprise this all is to us
and fundamentally it just it just feels
like being on the back of the school bus
you know these are like 12 year olds who
have been
texting each other and texting their
mates and then texting their mates about
the other mates and going we don't like
him anymore and
we don't like him and that it's just
that just
oh i used to have a night news editor at
the sunday mirror who would walk around
when he came in this night shift and say
what did they do all day and i am
tempted to say the same thing now about
the government
what are they doing when they're
supposed to be governing
because they're they're having some kind
of a breakdown
tim what do you make of all of this i
mean the daily mail um
our lead article in fact the opening
paragraph describes this as a
as an astonishing attack now you can
debate whether the astonishing applies
to the to the content of mr cummings
allegations
or the fact that he has launched an
attack on the prime minister because
frankly
plenty of people saw that one coming
absolutely
and i have mixed views on this uh story
to be honest
i think um susie and i were uh reviewing
previewing the papers
a few weeks ago when alex salmon
launched what supposedly was his
devastating
attack on nicola sturgeon and now of
course you know
just a couple of weeks ahead of the
scottish polls nicola sturgeon is still
riding high and so sometimes big attacks
don't actually materialize into a change
in
public opinion but regardless of whether
it's going to resonate in a sort of
popular opinion sense i think
what these uh attacks do
point to and i think they point to
something fundamentally
uh questionable about downing street is
a very
chaotic operation at the very least it
seems to be
a down history and this has certainly
been my limited experience
of the operation you know the prime
minister
is chaotic in how he manages
his affairs and that is not good
more seriously i think the prime
minister can get away with that because
that's probably
something of his reputation more serious
is the idea that somehow
money that was donated to the
conservative party for
political purposes was somehow misused
in the decoration of downing street and
if the
hmrc was to sort of get involved and
look at the tax implications of that
then we're talking about a much bigger
political problem for the prime minister
but we're not there yet um so we
shouldn't get ahead of ourselves
but you know two weeks ahead of local
elections lots of tory council
candidates will be out
uh tomorrow they're out today this is
not what they
need this is certainly not good for the
tory prospects in those elections
um susie as we as we can have a look at
the eyes front page and again
cummings declares war on on johnson but
the line that everyone has focused on in
the dominic cummings blog it is sad to
see the prime minister and his office
fall so far below the standards of
competence and integrity
the country deserves the problem for mr
cummings as i see it in all of this is
that two of the examples
the flat and the friend of of his of the
prime minister's fiancee
that perhaps he may have interfered in
it he said nothing at the time
in fact mr cummings has only waited
until he's been accused by number 10
of leaking text messages to point out
that the competence and integrity that
the country deserves
wasn't there whilst he was working for
the prime minister
exactly and i'm sure that's a point that
will be made at the select committee
when he goes before it in a month's time
he says he'll give it all the time
it wants and this is a man who two years
ago was found to be in contempt of
parliament for refusing to talk to a
select committee
i don't think um you know personal
principle is
really the issue as far as dominic
cummings is concerned because once you
have
once you start throwing hand grenades
you know one is never enough they're
very habit forming
and the issue really is not just what he
said here but what else does he know and
he hasn't said
and one of the lines which has come out
tonight which i find absolutely
fascinating trying to
see around the corner on this story and
see where it's going to lead to
is the fact that these renovations to
the downing street flat
apparently reportedly anything up to 200
000 pounds was spent on them
um perhaps 58 000 pounds uh went adrift
in terms of that being in the amount
that boris johnson couldn't afford to
pay and it came in from
donors and then had to get shuffled
around a bit but
down his street i'm now saying that he
has footed that bill personally
himself and if that's the case where has
the prime minister
who did not have 58 000 pounds a few
months ago
managed to come up with 58 000 pounds
now
to settle the bill just as the scandal's
kicking off
um what else does dominic cummings know
about possible sources of
money that going into or out of downing
street where they're from and what
they're for
what else does he know about text
messages and what's that message is
because you can bet your bottom dollar
you know he's not someone who's stupid
enough to have
sent them all out the first time around
he'll have someone in his back pocket
ready to go i'm sure
he's in front of that select committee
so on the one hand it's sort of
you know tin hats on i suppose if you're
working in downing street and on the
other hand
uh you know popcorn for the rest of us
um
tim and the the headlining the times
again dominic cummings declaring war on
unethical
foolish prime minister i mean we should
we should talk for a second shouldn't we
about boris johnson's
judgment in all of this if downing
street is correct and mr cummings says
deny the allegations you know
as we we should point out but downing
street is correct
you know boris johnson was warned time
and again by people you will know very
very well
about the man that mr cummings was and
the way in which he operates and the
dangers
of putting him so close to the center of
power in your government
yeah but neil and this is incredibly
personal for for me
i resigned from uh you know any
possibility of working for
the prime minister and when sajid javid
who has been a you know friend of mine
for 30 years you know the former
chancellor of this checker
javi is one of the few people who've
really come out well from this um
whole affair he left government because
he wasn't willing to put
up with what dominic cummings how
dominic cummings was behaving
it was obvious to an awful lot of us
that very early on although dominic
cummings comes up with brilliant ideas
he was running his affairs in downing
street in a very totalitarian
way he wasn't listening to other
people's advice and the prime minister
should have seen that
way before he did and sanji javid
sacrificed
you know one of the great offices of
state in order to
warn the prime minister that this
situation was
intolerable so yes there are big
questions uh for the prime minister
uh as judgment but the one thing that he
can sort of hold on to
i think at the moment in some sort of
salvage his
position is that i don't think there are
many people watching this program
tonight who think of dominic cummings as
mother teresa you know this is an
attack on the prime minister from
someone with
much public standing and i think downing
street will hope that because of that
they can get away with it but the issue
that susie has just raised
is really incredibly important it's been
something that people have speculated on
for a long time
is that we all suspect that the prime
minister's
outgoings are quite a lot more than the
prime ministerial salary
that the taxpayers pay him and how is
the difference between those two things
made up the redecoration of downing
street
is the most obvious thing that we've
been able to latch on to
journalists have been able to latch on
to to say how was this funded
but the worry i think if i was boris
johnson would be how many more questions
are now going to be asked
about that uh rumored gap
between earnings and uh expenditures uh
just before we get to the braces let's
have a look at the last front page on
this topic the daily telegraph again
cummings declares war on on prime
minister i've just been sitting here
thinking do you need to have
a kind of a a person who behaves in the
dominic cummings fashion
acting as as chief adviser chief of
staff gordon brown had one
you know tony blair had one theresa may
arguably had one and a half
i mean it does feel like there's a bit
of a theme here
yes it does appear to be that uh you
know if you are tough enough to
sort of be by the side of a prime
minister or a positive prime minister
they are happy to give you the job of
doing all the difficult things and
having the hard conversations and
knocking heads together
and there doesn't seem to be um
any sort of nuance in that you're either
an absolute
headbanger or you don't get the job
and that seems to be a great pity but i
think one of the points that tim raised
there is really important
actually and which at the end of all
this is going to be more relevant
perhaps to the voters
which is that how it is boris johnson
who relied so
much on dominic cummings uh for years
now through brexit and general elections
and
everything else um and who expended so
much of his own political capital to
protect him over the barnard castle
business
is prepared at this stage of the
uh game to apparently personally ring up
fleet street editors
and brief them that this is the mole and
attack someone who was formerly his
bagman and his chief enforcer
um you could only do that if something
far far worse is going to happen and to
pick a fight with dominic cummings i
would have thought
anyone who's ever tried to get into i
can't remember the name of it now that
nightclub in the northeast where he used
to be a
bouncer would probably tell you that was
quite a bad idea and just looking at
the guy's beady eyes there and i
wouldn't pick a fight with him on a dark
night
why the prime minister thought it was a
good idea to start um
having a go with him he knows where the
bodies are it's beyond me uh susie tim
we will pause there for just a second
uh but after the break oh god the
camera's over there perhaps i need to
drive to barnard castle as well uh will
it be necessary to keep wearing masks
this summer that depends who you ask and
we'll be discussing it next
i grew up in a small village in zimbabwe
and indeed
it's been a long journey to to get to
where i ended up
in the united nations but i always knew
from a very young age that this is what
i wanted to do with my life because at
the age of eight
a severe drought hit our village and
left us with nothing to eat and nothing
to drink
and one day i collapsed on the ground
and i couldn't move
i actually thought i was going to die
but then this incredible thing happened
an aid worker with the u.n found me she
gave me a ball of porridge and literally
saved my life and this was the moment
that sparked my dream and i thought
well gosh perhaps one day i too can just
be like her
and save the lives of others and so here
we are
i ended up being raised by my aunt and
my aunt was a medical doctor in zimbabwe
and she ran some of the largest hiv aids
clinics
and i started volunteering there because
i also realized that
if this issue was impacting my community
my own country my own people
then i ought to play my part in being
part of the solution and so
that sort of just continued to build on
my desire to do more for the world
better gender equality is needed in
every single country around the world
i mean we still live in a world where
not even one country has been able to
achieve gender equality so
it's not an africa issue alone it's a
global issue and that needs to be
addressed we need more women in
positions of power
so that they can also make decisions
that benefit women and girls
but i'm also very strong advocate for
true solidarity and
at the u.n i created a movement called
hefoshi
which really recognized that men had to
be part of the solution
i think we're all sick and tired of
living in a world where
every time something devastating happens
to a woman we have to ask the question
what was she wearing
well perhaps the men shouldn't do that
and there are a lot of good men who want
to
do just that they want to be on the
right side of history
and want to create a gender equal world
so we have to involve everyone
within three days of launching hi for
she we saw
at least one man in every single country
in the world joined the movement
and within the first five days there was
1.2 billion online conversation
which just told me that there's a lot
more good men out there who want to do
the right thing
and we just have to find a way to
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back to the press preview um tim
to you first
uh this quarter um the front page of the
daily express their
story smile no masks by the summer it
it feels sl i don't know what it is but
it feels slightly weird given what we've
been seeing
particularly in india and of course in
parts of europe over the past few weeks
yeah those pictures from you know we've
been talking about this dominic cummings
affair but those pictures from india are
beyond heart wrenching and i think there
will be lots of people
who have been nervous about kovit who'll
be very nervous about
this story but overall though i think it
is a good thing that we can look forward
to this and it is you know for all of
the
question marks about the government's
ethical behavior at the moment
you know the vaccine rollout has been a
huge success if anything
the success of the vaccine has been
understated
you know its efficacy is enormously
encouraging
and it probably will be safe for us
largely to stop wearing masks
quite soon but of course we've also seen
flu and other things
heavily reduced partly because of the
use of
masks so there'll be plenty of people
whatever the official guidance says
will continue to wear masks i think for
a long time yeah i mean so susie what's
your
what is your feeling as to where the
country generally is on the continued
wearing of mass i mean we
we regularly get polls on this and it
does show you know
most people seem quite sanguine if not
entirely happy
to keep wearing them for the greater
good
yeah i can't see me ever not wearing a
mask on the london underground if i ever
go on it again
at some point in the future probably for
the rest of my days i say never touch a
handrail on there
because i think we will become amateur
virologists in the past year
and it's probably worth bearing in mind
i mean hopefully we we can
start getting in the mast and everything
else but it's worth bearing in mind that
every
the previous waves that we've had of
this illness have been
uh sort of sparked and seeded by middle
class holiday
makers first time people going skiing in
northern italy
uh last year last winter and then second
you could be going holiday in spain over
the summer when the restrictions were
eased
and we had waves of the illness
afterwards each time now we didn't have
vaccines then
but we also only had the one variant now
we have many
so everyone should have cautious
everyone should have stayed at home and
watch the press preview instead of going
on holiday that's my view